the world's workshop is trying to get
back to work here in Shenzhen in South
China they're once again producing vapes
electronic cigarettes the domestic sale
and export coronavirus restrictions hit
production the company's chief executive
tells me in Beijing before speaking to
her though the ubiquitous checks
scanning this code displays data from my
mobile network showing my movements over
the last two weeks the company had to
find new suppliers after the ones in who
Bay Province the center of the outbreak
were cut off
Kate Wong estimates they're now a month
behind their forecasts the production
side have got a lot of impact so the
February and February the workers
supposed to come back from home from
Chinese New Year but the production got
delayed by 15 days the reason is the
workers have to stay at home for the
quarantine so we paid 20% higher to the
worker to speed up they're coming back
after weeks on lockdown the government
is keen to show that they're getting
back to business as usual so keen that
they've invited us on a tour
the checks like these are the new
business as usual what have we been
brought here to see you today
a girl for me maybe the Palio she's got
coming here for one the message at this
state-owned power plant is that they're
being productive while taking
precautions
propaganda tours like this are
interesting because they're meant as the
show of strength but they also reveal
anxiety we've been invited here to show
the world that China's economy is doing
just fine but if it were doing that fine
well they wouldn't have to make such a
big show of it a country's manufacturing
Purchasing Managers Index or PMI is a
measure of where the economy is going
it's a crucial number and according to
China's own statistics their PMI has
fallen off a cliff
it went from 50 in January to just
thirty five point seven in February
that's even worse than the financial
crisis of 2008 the previous low and
things are even worse for the service
sector mr. Zhu runs a communications
company in Beijing with 11 staff we meet
in a coffee shop that is working reduced
hours and experiencing much reduced
customers I first you are warmer we are
your you've got tight our nursery
January sales units yeah we're running
sugar one man banyan nursery and meal
with junior solo element yet almost or
merely enough even with the one there
are two options containing coronavirus
for running an economy of full steam you
can't really do both at the same time
China has found that out the rest of the
world will soon tom Cheshire Sky News
Beijing